اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرضون معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
هجوم اسرائيليون يستهدف مطار حلب الدولي
شمال غرب سوريا باربعه صواريخ ويخرجه عن
الخدمه
بوتين يهدد بريطانيا بالنووي اذا زودت
اوكرانيا بذخيره تحتوي يورانيوم
البرلمان الليبي يقرر استدعاء حكومه فتح
باشا غالبسالتها قبل المصادقه على ميزانيه
العام
ماكرون يساعد ضد المتظاهرين الغاضبين
والشرطه الفرنسيه تعتقل مئات الرافدين
لقانون التقاعد
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا افاد مراسو العربي
بسماع ذوي انفجارات متتاليه في عموم مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا
ان غاره جويه اسرائيليه استهدفت مطار حلب
الدوري مع ادى الى وقوع بعض الاضرار
الماديه في المطار واوضح مراسل العربيه ان
القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف المطاره باربعه
صواريخ ما ادى الى توقف حركه الملاحه
الجويه وهذا ثالث هجوم على مطار حلب خلال
سته اشهر
مشاهدي اللي بينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
محمد الاشقر اهلا بك محمد ماذا تقول
المعطيات حول هذه الغارات محمد وطبيعه
الاهداف التي قصفت ايضا اليوم
نعم يعني في الحقيقه اليوم استهدف تستهدف
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه مطار حلب
الدولي شرق حلب بصواريخ اطلقت من غرب
مدينه اللاذقيه من قباله السواحل السوريه
باتجاه المطار مما ادى الى حدوث اضرار
داخل المطار وتوقف حركه الملاحه فيه
وخروجه عن الخدمه بشكل جزئي طبعا وزاره
الدفاع التابعه للنظام اصدرت عبر صفحتها
الرسميه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وقالت ان المطار تعرض لغاره جويه
اسرائيليه تسببت بحدوث اضرار ماديه داخل
المطار طبعا بحسب المعلومات الوارده حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يتم تسجيل اي اصابه بشريه
في داخل المطار نتيجه هذا هذا الهجوم طبعا
بحسب المعلومات التي وصلتنا فان الاستهداف
كان لشحنه اسلحه
ايرانيه طبعا هنا بحسب شهود العيان في
محيط المطار قالوا ان
عده انفجارات متتاليه سمع دويها في المطار
بعد سقوط الصواريخ احدها كان انفجار ضخم
هذا الامر يشير الى الى
حدوث انفجار بمستودع اسلحه وذخائر او ما
شابه ذلك طبعا بحسب مصادر مطلعه على حركه
المطارات في عموم شمال في عموم سوريا
قالوا ان
طائره نقل
اقلعت من مطار دمشق يوم قبل يوم امس في
العشرين من الشهر
جاري وحطت في مطار النيرب العسكري المجاور
لمطار حلب الدولي وبقيت في المطار مده
ثمانيه ساعات لتعود
باتجاه مطار دمشق الدول طبعا
خلال يوم امس رصدت حرق حركه بين مطار
النيرب العسكري ومطار حلب الدولي في محيط
هذه
المنطقه يرجح ترجح هذه المصادر ان هذه
الطائره كانت محمله بالاسلحه والذخائر
التي اتجهت من دمشق الى هذه المنطقه طيب
هذا ما يتعلق بمنطقه حلب ماذا عن اللاذقيه
التي تعرض ايضا لغارات يقول النظام السوري
انها اسرائيليه
محمد هل تسمعني طيب يبدو انفقنا الاتصال
مع زميلنا محمد الاشقر مراسل العربيه من
ريف ادلب مشاهدينا ونتابع هذا الخبر
العاجل الذي سيظهر بعد قليل على الشاشه
اذا طيب
حتى
اذا
اذا مشاهدينا القبه الحديديه الاسرائيليه
تعترض مسيره اطلقت من قطاع غزه هذا بحسن
مراسله العربيه وسنعطيكم المزيد من
التفاصيل بعد تحذير الرئيس الروسي
بريطانيا من تزويد اوكرانيا من ذخيره التي
تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم اكدت وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه ان روسيا تحاول عمدا
تقديم معلومات مضلله وقال متحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع ردا على تصريحات بوتين
استخدم اليورانيوم المنظف في قضاء خارقه
لدروع لعقود كما اكد انه مكون بل مكون لا
مكون اذا لا علاقه له باسلحه او القدرات
النوويه مشيرا الى ان موسكو تدرك ذلك
تماما واضافت الدفاع البريطاني ان البحوث
المستقله خلصت الى ان تاثير استخدام
منخفض في المقابل اعتبرت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه خروف خطه بريطانيا لنقل
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
طائش اخر من قبل لندن وشدد الزخروف على ان
لندن تصاعد الصراع في اوكرانيا الى مرحله
جديده وتؤكد نيه الغرب الجماعي تدمير
اوكرانيا مؤكده ان استخدام قذائف
اليورانيوم يعد مظهرا من مظاهر اباده
الجماعيه ضد السكان بدوره حذر وزير الدفاع
الروسي
محتمل قائلا ان خطوات اقل متبقيه قبل حدوث
هذا الصدام بين روسيا والغرب وفق ما نقلت
الروسيه جاء تحضير شويغو بعدما سئل من
الصحفيين عما اذا كانت نيه بريطانيا من
تزويد اوكرانيا المنظم تعني ان العالم قد
بات على بعد خطوه واحده من حدوث صدام نووي
مشاهدينا من موسكو ينضم الينا مراسله
العربيه
مصطفى زارو اهلا بكم مع عبد الجواد ومصطفى
وابدا معك عبد الجواد بدات اهم تصريحات
والمواقف التي صدرت في موسكو حول تزويد
اوكرانيا من بريطانيا بقضاءها تحتوي على
اليورانيوم
مرحبا احمد نعم في الحقيقه يعني موسكو
خرجت منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر وضمت العديد
من مؤسساتها الرسميه ان كانت الخارجيه وان
كانت الدفاع الى ما تحدث عنه رئيس البلاد
يوم امس حول هذه القذائف موسكو طبعا في
ابرز تصريحاتها تحدثت الخارجيه بان ايصال
هذه القذائف الجانب الاوكراني هو
استخدامها يعتبر جريمه ضد الانسانيه بحق
المواطنين الذين سيستخدموا ضدهم هذا
السلاح وهذه القزائم طبعا هي نقطه تحول
كبيره في سير المعارك حسب وجهه نظر موسكو
موسكو تحذر من هذا الشيء بشكل كبير رحم
مجلس الدوما يتحدث عن ان استخدام مثل هذه
القذائف سيحول الوضع الى كارثه لذلك طبعا
القراءه السياسيه في البلاد رؤيه المحللين
احمد راحت تتحدث عن ضروره الاخذ بعين
الاعتبار ما قاله وزير الدفاع الروسي
باننا نقترب شيئا فشيئا
بطريقه سريعه من مواجهه نوويه قد تحدث
باعتبار ان موسكو ترى في هذه القذائف بانه
سلاح طبعا فتاك يدخل ضمن القائمه النوويه
وكانت قد ضربت امثله عديده على استخدامه
في صربيا لذلك طبعا ما قاله بوتين يوم امس
تقف عليه القراءه السياسيه في البلاد
والتصريحات
نتابع قراءات بريطانيا
مصطفى يعني بريطانيا تعتبر من اكثر دول
سخاء في دعمها لاوكرانيا كيف يمكن فهم فهم
موقف لندن من دعم كييف بهذه النوعيه من
الاسلحه
منذ البدايه وبريطانيا كانت سباقه في
تامين ما يلزم للجيش البريطاني سواء كان
بالاسلحه او حتى
بتدريب الجيش الاوكراني الذي تم تدريبهم
حتى الان ما يقارب من عشرين الف عنصر حتى
هذه اللحظه وهذا ليس بالجديد بالنسبه لما
اثير بخصوص الدخيل التي سيتم ارسالها الى
اوكرانيا تتضمن يورانيوم مستنفذ هذا
اليورانيوم بحسب وزاره الدفاع ان مخاطر
مخاطر اشعاع هذه الماده منخفض جدا وخاصه
بعد ان اجرى علماء من الجمعيه الملكيه
بحثا قيم هذه الماده وقال بان مخاطره
منخفض جدا وبالتالي هذا لا يؤثر على على
الصحه على الصحه او البيئه بشكل كبير لكن
معروف ان بريطانيا تستخدم
الماده اليورانيوم المنضب او المستنفذ في
ذخيرتها منذ عقود وموسكو تحاول ان تضلل
هذه المعلومات وتثير المزيد من من الاثاره
على في الساحه العالم وبالتالي بريطانيا
مصره على تقديم ما يلزم للجيش الاوكراني
وخاصه في مواجهه القوات الروسيه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبالتالي هذا ليس
بجديد لكن ما تم اثارته من قبل موسكو وهو
محاوله
لاثاره
العديد من التساؤلات حول عزم بريطانيا
ارسال هكذا قذائف ويجب التذكير بان
القذائف التي يتم استخدامها في الدبابات
شالنجر اثنين تحتوي على هذا المكون
الاساسي الذي قالت وزاره الدفاع بانه
منخفض مخاطره على يعني ترى فيه دعما
روتينيا لكييف لكن عبد الجواد على صعيد
زياره الرئيس الصيني شوجن بينك التي انتهت
اليوم في روسيا
كيف يمكن فهم الموقف الصيني ايضا خاصه ان
الصين دعت الى عدم التصعيد وكيف يمكن
الحديث ايضا عن ان هناك كما يقول بعض
المحايلين يعتقد ان هناك تغيرات ستحدث في
المشهد في فتره المقبله هل متاكده حول ذلك
احمد يعني في الحقيقه يعني ولم يتم
الاعلان رسميا حول هذا الموضوع لكن طبعا
كل التحليلات في الداخل الروسي راحت تتحدث
خلال اليومين الماضيين عن انه اعلان معلن
عن ولاده من الخاصره لقطب جديد بين موسكو
وبكين طبعا من ابرز تصريحات الجانبين يوم
امس في الملف الختامي لهذه السلسله من
اللقاءات كان طبعا الطلب من واشنطن
بالاتجاه نحو خفض التصعيد بما يخص الازمه
الاوكرانيه لكن نلاحظ بان الخارجيه
الروسيه عادت من صباح اليوم احمد وتحدثت
عن ان الولايات المتحده ترغب في تصعيد
الموقف ويجب مواجهه الطائرات والمقاتلات
يعني التابعه للولايات المتحده في المياه
التابعه للبحر الاسود والمياه الاقليميه
لذلك طبعا زياره الرئيس الصيني احمد يعني
كان لها اثر كبير داخل الواقع الروسي هو
دعم معنوي في الاساس هو توقيع عدد
الاتفاقيات ان كانت اقتصاديه وان كانت غير
ذلك في ملفات الطاقه وفي ملفات اخرى طبعا
يعني موسكو ترى في حليفتها بكين ولو لم
تكن حليفه عسكريه لكنها طبعا كان لكن هذه
الزياره كان لها اثر كبير على الواقع
الروسي ونلاحظ بان تصريحات موسكو اليوم
تخرج معانيه التصعيد في حال استمر الغرب
بهذه العمليه وبهذا التصعيد مصطفى هل من
خطوط حمر لهذا الدعم البريطاني الممتد
لكييف
يعني حقيقه في الوقت الحالي ليس هناك اي
نيه لارسال اي مواد
مشعه الى او او مثل اليورانيوم الى
اوكرانيا ولكن
بريطانيا تحاول ان تؤمن ما يلزم للدفاع
اوكرانيا عن سلامه مواطنيها واراضيها
وخاصه وان روسيا يعني استولت على اجزاء
كبيره من الاوكرانيه بالطبع بريطانيا يعني
تقدم على على ارسال اي اسلحه خطيره ممكن
ان يتم استخدامها
في الاراضي
بالتوجيه ولكن الهدف مصطفى
الماسونيه البريطاني هل هدف هو ضمان هزيمه
موسكو ام احداث توازن في ميزان القوه
لضمان موقف افضل
في اي مفاوضات مستقبليه
منذ ان بدات هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا ورساله
بريطانيا كما هو بالنسبه
للقاده في دول الغربيه وهو افشال مهمه
بوتين في الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبالتالي
بطريقه ما وهو يعني حزم القوات الروسيه
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا يعني مختصر
او محدود جدا في هذه في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وبالتالي ليست هناك اي نيه
لتوسيع دائره الحرب لتشمل الاراضي الروسيه
وهذا خط احمر بالنسبه للقدم لا يريدون ان
تكون اي مواجهه بين القوات الغربيه وخاصه
مع القوات الروسيه وهذا خط احمر كما
اعلنوا العديد من قاده وزعماء الدول
الغربيه بما فيهم رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
والرئيس الامريكي بايدن بالاضافه الى قائد
او الامين العام لحلف
هذه خطوط حمراء يريدون ان يؤمنوا ما يلزم
لدفاعه اوكرانيا عن اراضيها وشعبها ولا
يريدون الصدام المباشر مع القوات
الروسيه يجب تذكير ايضا بان عندما تم
مسيره امريكيه
قريبه من جزيره القرم كانت هناك مراجعه من
قبل الجيش الامريكي حتى
لا يمكن ان تتصادم القوات الغربيه مع
نظيرتها الروسيه فوق هذه المجال سواء كان
في يعني قريب من اوكرانيا او روسيا تريد
القوات الغربيه ان لا تصطدم ولا يعني يكون
هناك حرب نشبح حرب مباشره بين القوات
الغربيه والروسيه شكرا لكم
مصطفى زارو ومن موسكو العربيه عبد الجواد
الروج تحياتي لكما
اعلن حاكم شبه جزيره القرمخائيل روزوفو ان
البحريه الروسيه صدت هجوما لمسيره
الاوكراني على مرفاستوبال بشبه الجزيره
وفي التفاصيل قال رازوفاجيف ان اسطول
البحر الاسود صد هجوما سطحيا لمسيره
اوكرانيه
حاولت اختراق خارج قبل ان يتم صدهم من قبل
قوات البحريه والدفاعات الجويه على الجانب
الاخر اعلنت الاداره العسكريه في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
بالجيش الاوكراني اعلنت ان المضادات
الدفاعيه اسقطت 16 طائره مسيره من اصل
احدى وعشرين اطلقتها روسيا من جهه الشمال
خاصه من اقليم بريانيسك وذكرت في بيانها
اليومي ان الهجوم الروسيه بالمسيارات كان
مكثفا وان بعضها وصل بالفعل للعاصمه من
جانبها افادت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه بدات مؤخرا هجوما مضادا
الى الغرب من مدينه
من المرجح ان يخفف الضغط على طريق الامداد
في مدينه تشاز شيسيافيار ومنها الى
باخموتون واضافت الوزاره ان القتال مستمر
في محيط وسط المدينه لكنها ان الدفاع
الاوكرانيه لا يزال معارضا للخطر بل لخطر
التطويقتي الشمال والجنوب للمدينه
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل الرئيس
الصيني يغادر روسيا بعد زياره عززت محور
بكين موسكو
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد غدر
رئيسيه امتدت
موسعه مع رئيس روسيا
تركزت على التعاون الثنائي في اوكرانيا
واكد
التزمت بموقف محايد من الازمه في اوكرانيا
وتسعى للاعب دور البناء لخفض هذا التصعيد
قال البيت الابيض ان الصين اذا رغبت بلعب
دور بناء في اوكرانيا فعليها الضغط على
روسيا لوقف الحرب ووصف المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي في البيت الابيض
جون كيربي وصف الصين بالطرف غير المحايد
في هذا الصراع واضاف البيت الابيض انه لم
يرى اي شيء مما قاله الرئيس بوتين والرئيس
الصيني يدفع واشنطن للاعتقاد بان حرب
اوكرانيا ستنتهي كما قال جون كيربي ان
واشنطن لا تريد وقفا للنار في اوكرانيا
الان لان هذا سيجمد المعارك وسيعطي بوتين
الوقت والمكان لاعاده تجهيز قواته نتابع
لا نريد ان نرى وقف اطلاق النار في الوقت
الحالي لان وقف اطلاق النار وتجميد الخطوط
في مكانها يمنح بوتين بشكل اساسي الوقت
والمساحه التي يحتاجها لمحاوله اعاده
التجهيز واعاده التدوير والتعويض عن انفاق
الموارد
الرئيس الصيني تحدث عن خطط السلام مؤكد ان
بلاده التزم بموقف موضوعي وحيادي فيما
يتعلق بالحرب الاوكرانيه
فيما يتعلق بمساله الازمه الاوكرانيه
التزمت الصين دائما بمقاصد ميثاق الامم
المتحده ومبادئه وبموقف موضوعي عملت بنشاط
على تعزيز السلام والمفاوضات وحددت موقفها
على اساس مزايا الموضوع نفسه لقد وقفنا
دائما بثبات الى جانب السلام والحوار والى
الجانب الصحيح من التاريخ
اعلان المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه جنرال باتريدر ان واشنطن قررت
نقل نسخه قديمه من دبابات الى اوكرانيا
وتسريع عمليه التسليم في غضون ثمانيه الى
عشره اشهر
قررت وزاره الدفاع بالتنسيق مع اوكرانيا
تزويدها بدبابات ابرامز من طراز ام واحد
اي واحد ما سيسمح بتسريع وقت التسليم بشكل
كبير الى خريف هذا العام هذه الدبابات
تتمتع بقدره قتاليه مشابهه جدا لطراز ام
واحد اي اثنين
راحت اشتباكات عنيفه بين افراد الشرطه
الفرنسيه وعدد من المتظاهرين الذين تجمعوا
في ميدان الجمهوريه وسط العاصمه باريس
احتجاجا على اعتماد مشروع اصلاح نظام
التقاعد وجرت مواجهات متفرقه بين بعض
المحتجين الذين اطلقوا الالعاب الناريه في
اتجاه افراد الامن الذين بدورهم اطلقوا
القنابل المسيع للدموع لتفريقهم كما اضرب
المتظاهرون النيران في حاويات القمامه
المتراكمه في شوارع باريس نتيجه اضراب
عمار نظافه احتجاجا على المشروع الحكومي
وكانها ساحه حرب هذه هي حال شوارع فرنسا
هذه الايام حرائق مشتعله في شوارع كثيره
وقوات الشرطه والامن منتشره في كل مكان
تظاهرات عشوائيه تخرج في معظم المدن
الفرنسيه احتجاجا على اقرار قانون رفع سن
التقاعد الى 64 عاما
الاحتجاجات اخذت بعدا اخر بعد فشل
البرلمان في التصويت على مذكرتين لحجم ثقه
من الحكومه واعتبرت قوى المعارضه ان
الكلمه الان اصبحت للشارع وان اسقاط
الحكومه وحجب الثقه منها سيكون في الشارع
في العاصمه باريس ارهقت تنقل المحتجين في
كل شوارعها قوه الامن والشرطه التي اصبحت
تشن حملات اعتقالات عشوائيه ادانها
المسؤولون المنتخبون وعدد كبير من القضاه
محذرين من تبعاتها هذه احدى حالات
الاعتقال العشوائي التي تقوم بها الشرطه
والان يحاول المتظاهرون اقناع هؤلاء
الشرطه بان هذا الشخص ليس له علاقه بما
يحدث ومع انتقال المعركه الى الشارع لا
يبدو ان هذه الازمه ستنتهي قريبا فكل
الاطراف تحشد صفوفها لليوم الكبير في
الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر حيث سيكون
يوما للاضراب والتظاهر تدعو اليه النقبات
وكل الاحزاب اليساريه المعارضه فاديده
العربيه باريس
قنبله موقوته قد تنفجر في اي لحظه لتدمر
معها مؤسسات الجمهوريه الخامسه في فرنسا
ان توصلت الاحتجاجات الرافضه لتمرير اصلاح
نظام التقاعد المعارضه اكدت استمرارها في
اتباع كل الطرق لاسقاط قانون التقاعد ومعه
الحكومه بعد ان اخفق نوابها في الجمعيه
الوطنيه الفرنسيه في حجم الثقه عن حكومه
اليزابيث حيث اعلن رئيس الجمعيه الوطنيه
يا البراون بفيت عن فشلها
الاغلبيه المطلوبه للتصويت بحجم الثقه هي
287 بما انه لم يتم الوصول الى الاغلبيه
المطلوبه فلم يتم اعتماد اقتراح سحب الثقه
اما المحاميه ماتيلد بانو من حزب فرنسا
الابيه فوصفت الحكومه بالميته
فقط الى تسعه اصوات لحجب الثقه وكسر هذه
الحكومه واصلاحها الحكومه ميته بالفعل في
اعين الشعب الفرنسي ولم تعد تتمتع
بالشرعيه اتهامات بالبؤس المعنوي والسياسي
وعدم امتلاك الشرعيه الشعبيه ولا النيابيه
يواجهها الرئيس الفرنسي الذي بات مستقبله
على المحاك اتهامات قد تدخل البلاد في
ازمه حكم هي الاولى في تاريخ فرنسا
مارينلو بانزعيمه اقصى اليسار كان لها راي
اخر حيث اتهمت الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
بالفشل الذريع وبان سياسته ستساهم في
تمزيق الدوله الفرنسيه
صحيفه لوبينيون محسوبه على الليبراليين في
فرنسا اكدتنا الازمه قد تتفاقم والحكومه
ستتعرض لخسائر كبيره وهي تخوض معركه اصلاح
نظام التقاعد اما صحيفه لمن التل محسوبه
على اقصى اليسار فا شارت الى وضع لا يحتمل
وحاله من الانهيار في قواعد الحكومه
الفرنسيه
مراقبون للتطورات الحاصله اكدوا ان
استعمال منطق القوه في تمرير قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد سيؤدي لاغراق البلاد في
المزيد من الفوضى
[تصفيق]
واعتبر رئيس الفرنسي كلمه له امام نواب
الاغلبيه في مقر الاليزيه ان الجماهير
الغاضبه في الشارع ليس لها شرعيه امام
الشعب الذي عبر عن رايه من خلال ممثله في
البرلمان وذلك بعد ان اجرى ماكرون مشاورات
مع جميع الاطراف فغداه التظاهرات التي
تخللتها توترات حاده في كثير من المدن
الفرنسيه بعد ان اقر البرلمان اعتمادا
نظام التقاعد الجديد هذا واعتقلت الشرطه
الفرنسيه على خلفيه الاحتجاج على قانون
التقاعد
قرر البرلمان الليبي استدعاء حكومه فتح
باشاغا لمسالتها بشان مصروفات ونفقات عام
2022 واستجوابها عن اعمالها منذ تكليفها
وذلك قبل مصادقته على ميزانيه هذا العام
واوضح المتحدث الرسمي للبرلمان عبد الله
بلاحق ان اغلبيه اعضاء البرلمان طالبوا
باستدعاء الحكومه التي يوافقوا على
تعيينها قبل عام تحتسم حكومه الاستقرار
ومن المرجح ان يطلب اعضاء البرلمان من
رئيس الحكومه فتحي باشاغ خلال جلسه
المسائله التي لم يتحدد موعدها بعد تقريرا
مفصلا عن مصروفات الحكومه منذ توليها
مهامها في مارس العام الماضي واوجه انفاق
الاموال التي حصلت عليها الى جانب تقييم
ادائها وعملها
مشاهدينا من بنغازي ينضم الينا مراسله
العربيه محمد مسعود اهلا بك محمد اذا محمد
استدعاء حكومه باشا ومسالتها من البرلمان
هل ياتي في سياق اجراءات روتينيه تقاضي من
صلاحيات البرلمان كما هو معروف ام ان ذلك
يشي بتجاوزات ماليه ربما تكون قد ارتكبت
في العام الماضي
صباح الخير وكل عام وانتم وكل المشاهدين
بالف خير بمناسبه شهر رمضان المباركه هو
امر كان متوقعا منذ فتره خاصه بعد يعني
نشوب خلافات ما بين اعضاء مجلس النواب حول
حكومه بشاغه والصلاحيات الممنوحه للحكومه
ونتحدث ايضا في عدم قدرتها او اي بدا هذا
الخلاف منذ عدم قدرتها على الدخول الى
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس وايضا بالتالي عدم
الاعتراف الدولي بالحكومه وعدم تمكنها من
وضع يدها على ايرادات النفط او التحكم في
عوائد النفط المدخل الرئيسي
اللي قتل او للدوله بصفه عامه فبالتالي
تاتي هذه المطالب التي تقدم بها عدد كبير
من اعضاء مجلس النواب اكثر من 35 النائبه
تقدموا بهذا طلب من اجل استدعاء رئيس
الحكومه ومساءلته فيما يتعلق بمصروفات
الحكومه والحساب الختامي الذي تم صرفه من
الميزانيه التي اعت في العام الماضي
للحكومه بواقع 89 مليار دينار ليبي واوجه
الصرف وابواب الصرف في هذه الميزانيه خاصه
بان يعني الباب الاول المتعلق بالمرتبات
واجور المواطنين المتحكم به من قبل
الحكومه المتواجده في العاصمه الليبيه
اطراف حكومه الوحده الوطنيه رغم نيله
حكومه السيد بشار غاليه الثقه للشرعيه من
مجلس النواب وبالتالي كل هذه النقاط هي
يعني نقاط جوهريه واساسيه يستند عليها عدد
كبير من اعضاء المجلس النواب ويروم بان
الحقيقه جاء بعد تعهد السيد بشاغل لدخوله
الى طرابلس وبالتالي يحق لهم محاسبته الان
على المصروفات بالدرجه الاولى وايضا ضعف
اداء الحكومه وعدم تمكنها من الدخول من
الا
قامه الواضحه التي سببت في يعني هذا الامر
واستدعاء الحكومات بعد انتهاء هذه
المسائله ومسابقه البرلمان اذا على
الميزانيه لعام الجديد هل يتوقع لهذه
المصادقه ان تتم بسلاسه ويسر ام ان هناك
عقبات بما تعرقل هذا المشروع
بحسب حياه احمد فنحن نتحدث عن عديده
العقبات تواجه اقرار هذه الموازنه او
قانون الميزانيه العامه العقبه الاولى
تتمثل في زياده حجم هذه الميزانيه نحن
نتحدث مصادر خاصه للعربيه لان الميزانيه
لم يفص عنها حتى هذه اللحظه الان ولا تزال
في لجنه التخطيط بداخل مجلس النواب رقم
هذه الميزانيه هو 99 مليار دينار ليبي
بالتحديد اي ارتفعت عن الموازنه المقدمه
عن العام الماضي وبالتالي هناك هذه العقبه
او الاشكاليه الاولى التي يرى عدد من
اعضاء مجلس النواب من ضمن نقاط الاختلاف
على هذه الموازنه هو سبب زياده هذا الرقم
للموازنه العامه لهذا العام رغم تعذر
الحكومه وتقديمها لعدد من المسببات ابرز
وهو ارتفاع باب الاجور ليصل الى اكثر من
مليار دينار العقبه الثانيه وهي الخلافات
على مدى استمرار الحكومه خاصه فيما يطرحه
الانتخابات قبل نهايه هذا العام وبالتالي
يرى عدد اخر من اعضاء مجلس النواب بانه
كيف يمكن منح هذا الرقم الكبير لحكومه قد
لا تبقى الى نهايه هذا العام الجاري
النقطه الثالثه والعقبه الثالثه وهي
المتمثله في اشكاليه عدم دخول حكومه السيد
بشار الى طرابلس حتى هذه اللحظه الان رغم
كل التعاقدات المقدمه لاعضاء المجلس
بالدخول والتحكم في مقاليد السلطان اذا من
بنغازي كنت معنا مراسل العربيه محمد مسعود
شكرا لك محمد على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
واشنطن توبخ السفير الاسرائيلي عقب الغاء
الكنيسه لقانون فك الارتباط
هجوم الاسرائيلي يستهدف مطار حلب الدولي
شمال غربي سوريا باربع صواريخ ويخرجه عن
الخدمه
يهدد بريطانيا بالنووي اذا زودت اوكرانيا
بذخيره تحتوي يورانيوم ولاندا تتهمه
بالتضليل
البرلمان الليبي يقرر استدعاء حكومه فتح
باشا لمساعدتها قبل المصادقه على ميزانيه
العام
يساعد ضد المتظاهرين الغاضبين والشرطه
الفرنسيه تعتقل مئات الرافدين لقانون
التقاعد
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد استدعت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه سفير اسرائيل دعواشنت
على خلفيه اخاء الكنيسه الاسرائيلي قانونا
مستوطنين الى اربع مستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه وقال نائب المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه
للغايه من تحرك الكنيست مؤكدا موقف بلاده
بان المضي قدما في اقامه المستوطنات يشكل
عقبه امام السلام وتحقيق حل الدولتين هذا
وافاد وراس العربيه بان اسرائيل قامت
بتفعيل منظومه القبه الحديديه بعد راس
طائره مسيره فوق قطاع غزه واضاف انه لم
يتم تفعيل صفاره الانذار في اسرائيل مع
مشاهده مقاتلات اسرائيليه تحلق فوق قطاع
غزه
من القسم المشاهدين انضم الينا لانا قرصي
مراسله العربي اهلا بك لانا ما هي
المعلومات التي توفرت لديك حول ما يحدث
حول قطاع غزه
اهلا احمد نعم نحن نتحدث عن مسيره بدون
طيار اطلقت من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه في
قطاع غزه واطلقت الى السماء في الاجواء في
قطاع غزه وايضا يعني تدعي اسرائيل انها
اقتربت ايضا من المستوطنات الموجوده على
يعني المحاذيه لقطاع غزه وقامت فعليا
بتفعيل القبه الحديديه ما ادى ايضا الى
اسقاط هذه المسيره والان القوات
الاسرائيليه تجري يعني تحقيقات بشان هذه
المسيره ولكن دعنا ايضا نشير ان هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي تقوم القوات
الاسرائيليه باسقاط مسيره تم اطلاقها من
قطاع غزه الان ايضا نحن نتحدث عن عدم
تفعيل ايضا انذار ما ادى ايضا الى افزاع
وتخويف المستوطنين الموجودين في قطاع غزه
ولكن ايضا هذه ليست المره الاولى التي
تقوم فيها
بتفعيل القبه الحديديه دون اطلاق انذار
طيب الان نحن نتابع صورنا في الجانب الاخر
من الشاشه هي صور متداوله
تحليق طائرات اسرائيليه حول او في محيط
قطاع غزه اذا هذا ياتي في عقاب التوتر
الذي نجمع التحاليق ايضا طائره مسيره
انطلقت من قطاع غزه وارصدت فوق في محيط
هذا القطاع ايضا
واكد ايضا مراسله العربيه الان انه لم يتم
حتى الان تفعيل صفارات الانذار في المناطق
الاسرائيليه اذا الان هناك ايضا كان انباء
متداوله حول السقوط صاروخ في منطقه غير
ماهوله في محيط او في غلاف غزه هل
بالتاكيدات حول هذه المعلومه لنا
يعني حتى الان لا يوجد لدينا معلومات
موثوقه حول هذا الموضوع ولكن يعني
التوترات الموجوده في قطاع غزه هي موجوده
منذ الاسابيع الاخيره وتخوفات ايضا من
تفجر الاوضاع وتدخل قطاع غزه ايضا
بالتوترات الموجوده في الضفه الغربيه نظرا
لاننا نقترب كثيرا من شهر رمضان المتوقع
ايضا ان يكون هناك انفجار كبير في القدس
الشرقيه وايضا في الضفه الغربيه بسبب ايضا
استمرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه
باستمرارها
بالقوانين ايضا يعني شاهدنا ايضا ليله امس
كان هناك مصادقه على بالقراءه الثانيه
والثالثه ايضا بقانون وهو يعني الغاء بعض
بنود من انفصال اسرائيل من انفصال اسرائيل
احادي الجانب عن قطاع غزه وايضا الضفه
الغربيه ما يعني يؤدي الى ارجاع
المستوطنين الذين تم اخلائهم عام 2005 من
اربع مستوطنات قريبين من جنين ونابلس حيث
هناك يعني دائما تكون المشاكل والتوترات
شكرا لك من القدس الغربيه
تحياتي لنا
في السودان مشاهدينا اعلنت القوه المواقعه
على اتفاق الاطاري عن مصفوفه زمنيه لانهاء
العمليه السياسيه وتكوين حكومه الفتره
الانتقاليه مطلع الشهر المقبل فيما قال
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان خلال مخاطبتهم مواطنين بمنطقه ام
سياله بولايه شمال كردفان وسط السودان قال
ان بلادى مقبله على مرحله جديده وسيحدث
انتقال مرضي للجميع سيتم توقيع الاتفاق
النهائي يوم واحد ابريل القادم ان شاء
الله
موعد جديد اعلنته القوه الموقعه على
الاتفاق الاطار لانهاء العمليه السياسيه
وتشكيل حكومه الفتره الانتقاليه وصفه
تاكيدات المكون العسكري بالمضي قدما
لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه
المسار الهجري الان دع منه دعم كامل
ومتراجع منه لكن بنقول والله هذا المسار
اذا ما استصحب القوه الرئيسيه اذا ما
استصحب كل السودانيين سيتعسر قريبا ولن
يستطيع ان يمضي لكن الكتله الديمقراطيه
واطرافا اخرى ما زالت ترفض الانخراط في
اجتماعات هذا المسار وترى ان ورش هذه
العمليه لم تخاطب جذور الازمه الاسره
الدوليه نحن نقول بشكل مباشر انه المنطقه
غد تدخل في مواجهه سياسيه حقيقيه اذا وصل
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي مروره على قضيه شرق
السودان دون حلها بشكل شامل لن يرى
الاتفاق الايطالي نورا في اقليم شرق
السودان وهذا بمسابه الرساله واضحه لجميع
الجهات المعنيه بالاتفاق الايطالي
فيما تزال قوه تغيير الجذري التي تضم قوى
على راسها الحزب الشيوعي وبعض لجان
المقاومه تحمل لواء الرفض التام لاي حوار
مع المكون العسكري
الاتفاق الايطالي يعتبر ان القوه الجزريه
هي معارضه لهذا الاتفاق ستكون المعارضه
المدنيه السلميه في الشوارع وفي اي مكان
كمعارضه ولم يلتفت لهم وقدم لهم دعوات
كثيره ولكن لم يقبلوا بالجلوس مع
العسكريين الخمسه هنالك ايضا الاسلاميين
يضغط على الشارع والقوه السياسيه بان
يعودوا باي شكل من الاشكال عن طريق
الاذعان او فشل المرحله الانتقاليه تسمح
لهم بالعوده مره اخرى
فيما يظل الاسلاميون يرفضون ما اسموه
بالاقصاء ويبقى التحدي الاكبر بقدره هذه
الاطراف لتنفيذ ما اتفق عليه من مواقيت
لانهاء هذه العمليه السياسيه في ظل رفض
لفاعلين في المشهد السوداني قد يعقد كثيرا
من سير هذه العمليه سالم الهاشمي العربي
الخرطوم
شكرا لك اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اذا
سجل المركز الباكستاني الى الارصاد الجويه
هزه ارضيه بقوه السبع درجات فاصل السبعه
على مقياس ريختر متسبب من مقتل اربعه
اشخاص واصابه 80 اخرين بحسب هيئه الطوارئ
في البلاد واشارت هيئه الارصاد الى ان
مركز الهزه في منطقه هندوكوش الجبليه
شماليه البلاد التي تعتبر نقطه تماس بين
صفيحتين الاوراسيه والهنديه واحس بشده
الهزه سكان العاصمه اسلام اباد ومناطق
واسعه من افغانستان والهند
قال كبير مديرين منتجات في جوجل جاك
كراوزيك ان الشركه بدات الاصدار العام
لروبوت الدردشه الخاص بها بارد سعيا لجذب
المشتركين والحصول على ردود فعل على
البرنامج الذي تخوض به غمار المنافسه في
عالم الذكاء الصناعي مع تشاد
واضاف كرازيكا انه بالاضافه انه سيتسنى
للمستخدمين في الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
في بادي الامر الانضمام الى قائمه
الانتظار للوصول الى بارد وفي عرض توضيحي
اظهر كراوزيك كيف ينشئ بارد نصوصا باكملها
في لحظه بطريقه تختلف عن الذي يكتب
الاجابات كلمه بكلمه ويشتمل ايضا على ميزه
تعرض ثلاثه اصدارات مختلفه او مسودات لاي
اجابه وبهاء ابحث في جوجل اذا رغب
المستخدم في الحصول على نتائج من على
الانترنت لاي سؤال يريد معرفه اجابته
لم تتصور الحكومه الصينيه ان تمويلها
لمشروع مؤسسه ناشئه تعمل على تطوير
خوارزميات تدرس السلوك البشري سيتحول الى
عملاق تكنولوجيا يؤرق الحكومات قبل
المنافسين
من مشروع ناشئ ولد ليدرس سلوك الشعب
الصيني الى ما يصفه الغرب بالتطبيق
الشيطان الذي غزه هواتف اكثر من مليار شخص
محاربته باتت مشروعا وطنيا
البدايه كانت عام 2012 حينها كانت شركات
وادي السيليكون في امريكا تسيطر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
وتتسابق وراء تطوير نظام الخوارزميات
الاذكى ولدت منصه الصينيه التي وصفت بوافد
متاخر لن يقدر على منافسه العمالقه
سنوات قليله وتيك توك يكسر احتكار الكبار
لا بل ينافسهم في بلدانهم السر لا يكمن في
خوارزمياته الذكيه فقط بل ايضا في تنظيفها
اذ يقضي المتصفحون وقتهم في البحث عن ما
ينبئ اطباقهم يعرض تيك توك حريه الخيار
مره واحده
ليتكفل الذكاء الاصطناعي بدراسه نفسيه
المستخدمين واحياء رغبات يجهلونها
[موسيقى]
وهنا الخطر يقول المختصون افراز الدوبامين
او هرمون السعاده في كل مره ينال المحتوى
اعجاب المتابعين الا ان الدوبامين المفرز
يتضاعف حال الاعجاب بمحتوى مفاجئ امر لا
توفره منصه منافسه للتيك توك الحكومات
الغربيه انتقدت امتلاك الصين ملفا نفسيا
عن مواطنيها الذين يواجهون خطر الادمان
لمنتوج اسيوي هي خطوه اولى فقط يليها
الكسل والعزله وانخفاض معدلات التفكير
[موسيقى]
اما بكين فلم تجد تفسيرا بما يعيشه تيك
توك سوى انه صيني بالنسبه للخبراء تيك توك
مجرد درس عن الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي لا
ينافس البشر بل يتطور على حساب قدراتهم
[موسيقى]
تزدحم الاسواق الشعبيه والمولات في تعز
بالباعه والمشترين مع حلول شهر رمضان
المبارك حيث تتجه عشرات الاسر الى اسواق
المدينه لشراء احتياجات رمضان رغم ارتفاع
اسعار السلع وتدهور الاوضاع المعيشيه
الى اسواق المدينه هذه تتدافع عشرات الاسر
يوميا لشراء احتياجات رمضان ولعلها طقوس
الاعتاد عليها سكان تعز كل عام لكن
الغالبيه منهم هذه المره قد لا يعود الى
منزله بنصف احتياجاته بسبب تدور الوضع
المعيشي وانقطع الرواتب وتراجع دخل الفرد
الى معدل النصف نتيجه الحرب الحوثيه
كثيره حوائج اليوم اليوميه اللي ما تطلعش
3000 4000 مليون ما تكفيش مصروف عشاء من
غير المعونات اللي تاخذه من قبل مصروفنا
اليومي من الكفينا كافي فرق الاسعار على
السنه الماضيه بشكل فرق كبير العمل الماضي
كان المواطن الشريعه عشره كيلو بطاط
سلبطات كان هذه السنه اشتري نص كيلو بطاطا
الكبير
في الاسواق الشعبيه والمولات الكبيره ايضا
تلمح ابصار المشترين اصنافا من السلع
لكنها لا تجد بينها سلعه واحده معروضه
بسعر منخفض بمناسبه قدوم شهر رمضان ولذا
فانما يتوفر من نقود بحوزه شخص ما من
المتسوقين يحرس اي ينفقها في شراء
احتياجاته الاساسيه من مواد غذائيه وتمور
فقط وهكذا يقتصر استقبال غالبيه الناس
للشهر الكريم
كنا في السابق ناخذ الحاجات الاساسيه يعني
الواحد يخرج معه 50 الف يرجع بمصاريف
رمضان كامل الان تخرج معك 50 الف تشتري
كسبر وتروح يعني فرق شاسع بين كل في كل
سنه يستاد في هذه السنه طبعا الزياده
الزياده وازياد
طبعا احنا نطالب التجار يعني برحمه
للموظفين لرحمه بالمواطنين خاصه اللي ليس
لهم دخل يعني هنا تطلق المناشدات لخفض
الاسعار بينما في المنافذ التي تسيطر
عليهم بلشه الحوثي تفرض الاتاوات والرسوم
البيهضه على البضائع والسلاح بل وتحول
وجهتها عبر طرق بعيده بسبب الحصار المفروض
على تعز منذ سنوات ما يتسبب بحسب التجار
برفع الكلفه الشرائيه للبضائع الى الضعف
ويفاقم من معاناه اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
نسمه في تعز فائل سعيد العربيه تعز
احتفلت العربيه بمرور 20 عاما على تاسيسها
في حفل في الرياض حيث اكد القائمون على
المحطه مواصله العمل للحفاظ على موقع
العربيه الرائد في فضاء الاعلام العربي
متابع
[موسيقى]
نشراتنا الاخباريه من قناه العربيه في
الرياض احتفلت العربيه بعيد تاسيسها
العشرين في مارس 2003 انطلقت من مجموعه ام
بي سي وبعد ذلك التاريخ بعقدين لا تزال
رقما اساسيا في فضاء الاعلام العربي
بحضور لافت من وزراء سعوديين وعدد من
الاعلاميين والفنانين
استعرض رئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ وليد الابراهيم الهدف وراء تاسيس
العربيه وما انجزته في عشرين عاما
ولدت العربيه من غرفه اخبار ام بي سي
لتكون المتخصصه والشامله في مجالها
ومنذ البدء
كانت مشروعا وطنيا سعوديا
بعد ان ظهرت القنوات الفضائيه الاخباريه
الناطقه بالعربيه
والتي سعى بعضها
لتوجيه الراي العام
وفقا لاجندات معينه
كانت في اغلب الاحداث تتخذ مواقف سلبيه من
المملكه ومن دون الخليج
طريق نجاح العربيه لم يكن سهلا ابدا
فارواح فقدت في سبيل الوفاء بوعد المحطه
ان تعرف اكثر كما
ركز سام بارنت الرئيس التنفيذي لام بي سي
في كلمته
يجدر بي ان اسلط الضوء على 18 شخصا فقدوا
حياتهم في سبيل خدمه قناتنا في السنوات
العشرين الماضيه ويجب الا ننسى مطلقا
المخاطر التي تواجهها طواقمنا والتضحيات
التي يقدمها الكثير من الصحفيين والثمن
الذي دفعته العربيه نفتخر بهم جميعا ونحن
ملتزمون بمواصله عملهم بذات المستوى من
النزاهه على مدار العشرين عاما القادمه في
اشاره على ما يبدو في بدايه طريقها اختارت
العربيه ان يكون نهجها هو المهنيه بعيدا
عن الشعبويه والدعايه
وكانت عنصرا في معركه التنوير بعيدا عن
العنف والجهل كما يقول ممدوح المهيني
المدير العام لقناتي العربيه والحدث
العربيه لم تركن ابدا لتاريخها الطويل ففي
عيدها العشرين تعلن عن مزيد من التوسع
باطلاق اذاعه العربيه اف ام نعم انا مدير
محظوظ
لانني معكم في الرياض عاصمه المستقبل
وقبله المؤسسات العالميه الكبرى حيث تبث
العربيه نشراتها وبرامجها من استديوهاتها
وتستمر في توسعها
والياذن لمعالي وزير الاعلام وسعاده رئيس
مجلس الاداره
بالاعلان من هنا من الرياض باطلاق اذاعه
العربيه اف ام
[تصفيق]
لتكون الاقرب دوما والاقدر على استجابات
والاقدر على الاستجابه الاحتياجات الجمهور
المختلفه في احتفاليه عيد العربيه العشرين
ينظر مدير المؤسسه بعين الى ماض مشرف
وبعيين اخرى الى مستقبل تسعى خلاله
العربيه الى الحفاظ على موقعها في مقدمه
فضاء شديد التنافسيه
وفي نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
نذكره بابرز العناوين
هجوم الاسرائيلي يستهدف مطار حلب الدولي
شمال غربي سوريا باربعه صواريخ ويخرجه عن
الخدمه
يهدد بريطانيا بالنووي اذا زودت اوكرانيا
بذخيره
تحتويمه بالتضليل
البرلمان الليبي يقرر استدعاء حكومه
قبل المصادقه على ميزانيه العام
مكروه يساعد ضد المتظاهرين الغاضبين
والشرطه الفرنسيه تعتقل مئات الرافدين
لقانون التقاعد
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]